bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on vient que
de parler justement du taux de
participation record on a vu que c'était
vraiment le l'engouement les américains
voient là sont très concernés par ces
élections en tout cas cette année la
participation s'annonce historiquement
élevé est-ce que ça illustre en quelque
sorte justement cette amérique est
aujourd'hui divisée fracturé en deux oui
tout à fait je pense que ça montre que
cette élection est particulièrement
importante est lourde de sens pour les
états unis que les américains
probablement pense que c'est une
élection historique
c'est une amérique comme vous l'avez dit
qui est totalement polarisé divisé en
deux entre des partisans de trump qui
sont qui le qui le soutiennent très
fortement et des gens qui ne peuvent
plus supporter ces sorties sur twitter
ses sorties médiatiques et son style qui
est lui est très particulier donc les
gens se sont particulièrement mobilisés
ils sont également divisés sur la sur la
gestion de la crise du coc vide ce qui
est une crise en fait qui est multiple
puisque cette crise est également une
crise économique
donc les gens se sont emparés de cette
élection
on peut penser que le taux de
participation serait autour de 67 pour
ça on n'a pas encore les chiffres
aujourd'hui mais généralement en tout
cas pour la dernière élection le taux de
participation était de 60%
donc c'est une grande grande avancée en
fait pour la pour la participation
électorale
les gens ont peut être également eu peur
de ne pas pouvoir voter le jour j et
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont envoyé leur
vote par correspondance ou qu'ils ont
voté par anticipation
comme vous l'avez dit plus de 100
millions d'électeurs américains ont
déposé leur vote dans les boîtes aux
lettres ou bien se sont déplacés pour
voter avant la date du 3 novembre
une amérique polarisé comme vous l'avez
dit avec cette mobilisation est ce que
ça ressemble plus justement un
référendum pour ou contre donald trump
ces élections oui je crois que
l'élection se fait autour de la de la
personne de donald trump autour de ce
qu'il incarne
c'est pas forcément ça sera pas
forcément un vote pour baden baden
l'emportent ce sera surtout soit
un vote contre 30,6 et bat edel qu'il
importe soit un vote pour pour le
confirmer dans son poste je pense que
c'est sa personnalité et son style qui
polarise l'amérique aujourd'hui baden
n'est pas un une personnalité qui a
particulièrement soulevé l'adhésion des
démocrates mais les personnes qui votent
démocrate aujourd'hui aux états unis se
positionne très clairement par contre
contre donald trump s'est écrite sa
critique des médias
sa gestion de la crise du coc vide son
traitement des femmes son traitement des
minorités raciales puisque du côté des
démocrates et des gens qui votent contre
trump et pour baden
ils ont été érigés un parent par ses
sorties peu modéré on peut le dire de
donald trump sur bien bien des sujets
des sujets très clivant où il a souvent
attiser les divisions en compte alors
qu'abidal incarne justement un candidat
qui rassemblerait l'amérique et et il a
ce côté très calme très rassurant
et qui intéresse particulièrement les
gens qui veulent le retour à une
présidence disons plus normal alors
céline eu le temps plein on l'a vu dans
la course aux grands électeurs joe biden
a longtemps été devant donald trump
aujourd'hui donald trump commença à
voile à rattraper son retard
by donne pour l'instant en récolterez
225 électeurs donald trump 213 on a vu
le président américain qui a enchaîné
les meetings ces derniers jours
qu'est ce qui a changé la donne selon
vous ans attendait justement à une vague
bleue on a l'impression que c'est plus
une vague rouge aujourd'hui aux états
unis
oui tout à fait on s'attendait à un
raz-de-marée pour byden et là on se rend
compte que les sondages
encore une fois on sont démenties par
par la réalité des résultats qui sortent
comme on l'a dit de manière très
graduelle puisqu'on n'a pas les
résultats définitifs mais c'est vrai que
on s'attendait à cette vague bleue en
réalité trump remporte il semblerait la
floride le texas à l'ohio et l'iowa qui
étaient des états
qu'on appelle des swing states aux états
unis des batteurs g states donc les
états pivots qui peuvent faire basculer
l'élection
donc le texas on pensait que byden
pouvait faire une poussée au texas en
l'occurrence ça n'a pas été le cas en
arizona c'est plus c'est plus étonnant
il semblerait que ben laden soit en tête
mais là encore les résultats définitifs
ne ne sont pas connues ce qui concerne
les derniers jours de la campagne je
pense qu'ils ont été décisifs puisque
trump s'est déplacé il a continué les
meetings il a continué à être présent
sur le terrain alors que byden s'est
montré beaucoup plus discret sans doute
pour montrer que la crise du coc vides
étaient là et qu'il prenait en compte ce
risque alors que trump a continué à
faire campagne comme si de rien n'était
et a montré que pour lui le co vide
n'est pas un obstacle n'est pas
forcément une grave crise alors que
bayonne veut se montrer comme le
candidat plus responsable par rapport à
cette crise et je pense qu'effectivement
la présence de donald trump sur le
terrain a pu influencer le résultat des
élections aujourd'hui la crise sanitaire
a souvent été un enjeu majeur dans la
campagne électorale des mots très durs
de la part de joe biden envers donald
trump donald trump qui a tout le temps
minimisé justement le coronavirus il en
a joué le président américain voilà pour
pour gagner justement plus électorat
pour rafler un petit peu les grands
états aux états unis oui tout à fait il
ya beaucoup d'américains qui aujourd'hui
sont
sont contre le port du masque beaucoup
d'américains qui minimise cette crise et
le fait que donald trump et était
lui-même touché par la maladie et qu'ils
s'en soient relativement bien sorti même
très bien sortie est très rapidement a
certainement joué en sa faveur en sa
faveur
il en a beaucoup joué il a mis en scène
son retour à la maison blanche il a il a
voulu se montrer comme un homme fort un
homme physiquement fort malgré son âge
puisqu'il a plus de 70 ans
tout comme joe biden et il a
constamment renvoyait justement joe
biden à asson son grand âge alors qu'il
n'a pas une grande différence d'âge avec
lui en l'appelant systématiquement
sleepy zhao et en se montrant au
contraire un homme un homme fort un
homme énergique un homme dynamique qui
va sur le terrain juste après être sorti
de cette maladie qui quand même là là là
affaibli pendant au moins quelques jours
et je pense que ça ça lui a été sans
doute très très bénéfique très salutaire
vous restez avec nous céline le temple
est pour voilà analyser ces élections
américaines